Okay, questions from the chat. We are needing to replace carpet in our house.
I've heard there could be some toxic outgassing with new carpeting.
Damity concerns, recommendations about new carpeting and how to impact someone with cancer.
Well, there's definitely toxic outgassing with all new carpet.
Carpet is obviously made with, you know, as a chemical and many carpets are sprayed with fire
retardants. I can't remember the name of the fire retardant, but that is a major
neurotoxid in itself. And so, yeah, you know, but you know, going the round of a natural
wool-based carpet to be extremely expensive and doesn't necessarily wear well and it's not very
state-resisted at all. My son put in a, in their nursery, he put in a wool-based carpet that was
expensive and it just, it did not, it was horrible actually as far as wear and, and state resistance
goes. It was just, it was just, they just said it wasn't just a big mistake.
So, you know, what do you do? Maybe wait till the summertime where you can open up all the windows
and turn the fans on and try to, you know, get that stuff out of your house. I can't remember
who it was. Some movie star years ago had a video of hers. Heard her husband had a son,
and he ended up with a severe neurotoxic disease diagnosis. They said he was
um, ventilator-y charted at the time with some strange neurotoxic disease. They ended up detoxing
him. Going to actually a chiropractor out in California did detoxing the paramedic desiology and
it found out that he was, he was, uh, he was toxic with the fire, uh, the fire retardant chemical,
I believe, and some other chemicals did complete detoxing. They tore all the carpet out of their
house. The sun got better, um, and they wrote multiple articles about it and living, trying to have
a clean house. So, a perfectly clean house then would not include any carpeting and would all be
hardwoods or tile and um, that's just not real practical. I mean, they'll use throw rugs. Well,
the throw rugs have chemicals in them too. I mean, it's, it's just difficult to balance that out.
We certainly don't do that. We have wall-to-wall carbonated areas of our house. We have some wood
in areas of our house and obviously tile in the bathrooms. But yeah, it's, it's a difficult thing.
I mean, some people are going to have more issues with that and it all depends upon different
sensitivities. It depends on if they have damage to brain cells already and they have microglial
priming. They're going to be more sensitive to those type of chemicals. If they have compromised to
their liver detox pathways, they're going to have a difficulty getting that stuff out.
They're going to be more susceptible. Just like people are more susceptible to different toxins
based upon, you know, the level of toxicity that they're dealing with right now. And certainly,
if they're dealing with, uh, with cancer or some other, you know, more co-orbidity. So yeah,
you just have to find a balance. Maybe it's like, okay, well, we're just going to do it in the
summertime and, you know, try to open the windows and leave the fans blowing and try to just maybe
maybe get the carpets cleaned. Even after we get them put in, always when you get your carpets
cleaned, you should clean with just hot water alone, never any soap or chemicals ever, ever, ever
when you get carpets cleaned. There's services now that do that. Or if you do it yourself,
a friend to carp a cleaner or do it yourself, just with hot as water as you can possibly get,
um, used to have a patient years ago that had a carpet cleaning service and he just cleaned
carpets with boiling water. And, um, and she's got great results. Never used anything, but the stuff
that he pulled out of carpets, the cleaning solution that was left behind from other cleaners was
amazing. So maybe try that. That's another, you know, possible solution to get some of that stuff out.
A couple of years ago, I had a doctor, friend to mind, whose son is 12-year-old son or something,
was having major neurotoxic issues. I tested him. He tested positive for, for fire retarded chemicals.
And I said, I don't know what this is. It's fire retarded chemicals. Do you have an idea where he's
getting that? Um, this was years ago before I knew anything about really fire retarded chemicals.
And he said, well, yeah, we just got a brand-new pouch. Um, and he's been sleeping on the pouch.
So all he did is change where he's sleeping and all the symptoms went away. Plus he took some
supplements to help detox it. So these things can be major issues. All the furniture you buy has
that stuff in it. Uh, all baby clothes have that stuff in it. That's why my kids typically buy this
natural, you know, organic cotton baby clothes even though they're more expensive. You don't want
to put that garbage on your little baby. So, um, yeah, it's just a matter of trying to strike a balance.